uh hey sandra just right around the
corner from john here and you know it
started on this trip
earlier this week with a g7 statement to
this effect pushing
on the w.h.o in covid19 we have just
gotten a statement
from the united states and european
union that had some consultations in
brussels saying quote
we call for progress on a transparent
evidence-based and expert-led who
convened phase 2 study
on the origins of covet 19 that is free
from interference
and we commit to working together
towards development and use of a swift
and independent means
for investigating such outbreaks in the
future china's government refuses that
an independent examination
into the origins of the virus in china
to determine whether this came from
nature
or the wuhan institute of virology and
with that
republican congressional leaders are
calling for another domestic
inquiry definitely not using the world
health organization to investigate why
don't you just ask china to investigate
it as well
hold china accountable for what they
have done and the deaths that they have
caused around the world
secretary of state anthony blinken who
was also on this trip with president
biden
called the world health organization's
first investigation
highly deficient and that there needs to
be accountability for china though it is
unclear what exactly that accountability
will be
and if the united states and biden
administration determine it
whether american allies will join the
u.s
in that accountability for now officials
are pointing to that
independent review that the u.s
intelligence committee is looking into
to look into whether this was a lab leak
or came from nature which is due by the
end
of august sandra all right good stuff
from there a change of scenery for you
as well rich edson thank you
john uh yeah he's experiencing
the same beautiful scene that we are
there's another scene there on capitol
hill let's bring in senator rand paul of
the great state of kentucky
so senator paul the w.h.o being
instructed by the g7 and we should point
out the who is headquartered here in
geneva
to undertake a second review of the
origins of covet 19 and whether or not
it came out of the laboratory
didn't einstein once say that the
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing over and over again
expecting a different result here's the
problem the who investigated this the
first time
we suggested three people to send to
china they rejected all three and they
accepted a guy named peter dezak
who was the one who funded the lab so
you can't have the people
like peter anthony fauci or peter dazak
who
who were part of the funding mechanism
to send these funds to wuhan lab
you can't have them investigating
themselves they have a
definite conflict of interest because if
if this
pandemic started a lab that the u.s was
funding
the people advocating for the funding
obviously will have
you know culpability at least moral
culpability so they can't be
investigating themselves
the who did a terrible job the first
time there needs to be investigation but
i've been advocating
for a congressional investigation in the
senate i've asked two committees that
i'm on
homeland security and the help committee
the health
labor and pensions committee to
investigate this i haven't heard back
from the democrat chairman so far
but i think this should be investigated
i don't think it has to be partisan
we should all want to know how this
pandemic started but we should all want
to know so we don't have this happen
again with another lab leak
of an even more dangerous virus
the the communique that came out of the
g7 summit in cornwall
england talked tough about china in
terms of wanting to get to the bottom of
coronavirus
had something to say about their human
rights abuses the chinese communist
party basically took a page out of
vladimir putin's playbook and said who
cares what a handful of nations say
we're looking toward the g20 summit uh
this fall
it's a much bigger group does the g7
have have they have to try to put the
screws to china particularly when
countries like germany are really you
know getting into bigger economic deals
with with china
where france is being invested into a
much greater degree i mean the chinese
bought club med for pizza
so do they have the half to be able to
put the screws to china
i think it's very difficult for any
international body to make another
country that doesn't want to listen
behave i do think though that the entire
world was affected by this pandemic over
three and a half million people have
died
the type of research that they're doing
in china has even deadlier implications
one of the viruses they've been working
on has a 15
mortality which would be 15 times
greater over
50 million people dead so yes the whole
world has a self-interest
in making sure that china behaves but
the only way we'll get them to behave is
with
ostracism by the whole world and i agree
with president trump we shouldn't have
been we should have gotten out of the
who and say we only get back in
you only get us money we only get any of
our money
if there's a real honest-to-goodness
investigation of where this virus came
from
let me get you to weigh in on tomorrow's
summit for a little bit if i could uh
when he was leaving nato
president biden suggesting that uh putin
is a worthy adversary dialing back his
criticisms just a little bit
also with a preview of tomorrow's summit
saying he's not looking for conflict
with russia
listen here then i'll get you to react
on the other side
i'm not looking for conflict with russia
but that we will respond if russia
continues its harmful activities
and we will not fail to defend the
transatlantic alliance
or stand up for democratic values
is dialing back the west best way to
deal with vladimir putin or should he go
into that meeting tomorrow with his
gloves off
you know i think we're approaching a
time period that's not uh too dissimilar
than the cold war
in the cold war you know russia the
soviet union had all kinds of human
rights abuses
we objected to it we spoke out against
it and yet reagan did at some point sit
down with gorbachev and talk about
nuclear arms control
i think we have the same sort of
scenario now you know there's great deal
of evidence of poisoning of their
opponents
of people being poisoned around the
world by a russian nerve agent which
you know seems to have come from russia
so the thing is is we have all those
things they all need to be condemned but
at the same time we still need to have
conversation with both russia and china
over nuclear arms control
we need to make sure that the world is
assured that we are not
a believer in the first strike of other
nations and that we are a civilized
nation that wants to reduce nuclear arms
i think those are important no matter
how bad the human rights
records are of other countries that we
continue to have some dialogue
give me just a couple of seconds of this
because we're just running short of time
here senator paul
should there be a joint press conference
tomorrow between the two leaders
should president biden get up there on
stage with putin and talk tough publicly
you know i think uh optics are important
and i don't know if i have the best
advice on whether it should be joint or
separate
but i think there are ways uh to make
our case known
to condemn human rights abuses but at
the same time still be willing to have a
dialogue with russia and china
so it's a difficult and delicate dance
diplomacy
but the main thing is we cannot cut
ourselves off we cannot
refuse to have dialogue we still need to
have open dialogue with both china and
russia
yeah you don't just talk to your allies
and talk to your adversaries as well
senator rand paul of kentucky thanks for
joining us appreciate it